Hey Youtubers it’s Charlie, so much to talk
about in this edition of Marvel Tuesday.
There’s been a whole lot of Avengers 2 stuff
coming from the set, like Ultron picks and
a brand new Iron Man suit.
Plus in a recent interview Chris Evans talked
about not playing Captain America anymore.
So I’m going to start this video with a
question.
What would happen if, In Avengers 2.
The Avengers weren’t the good guys.
What if the rest of the world thought of them
as the villains?
I have a couple of big reasons I think this
is going to be the case, for at least the
biggest part of the story.
And I’ll address some of those Captain America
rumors as it applies to an Avengers roster
change.
Because it all ties together.
Real quick though, if you’re finding me
for the first time and saying WTF Marvel Tuesday,
I just make Marvel Movie videos every Tuesday,
just because I’m usually already doing Agents
of SHIELD stuff.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything and
please leave your suggestions for future movie
videos to do.
So what’s this about evil Avengers.
This isn’t going to be a version of Dark
Avengers.
Which came after Civil War in the comics.
It was just a bunch of Super Villains disguised
as superheroes.
No, I’m talking more about popular opinion
as it applies to hero worship in the Marvel
Universe.
So first off we have to talk about fandoms.
Remember way back in the first Iron Man movie.
Robert Downey Jr came out as Iron Man during
a live press conference.
He never hid his identity and became this
larger than life personality.
Then after the battle of New York in the first
Avengers movie.
They all became celebrities inside that Universe,
they’re all worshipped as heroes.
So what happens when they lose the public
trust and everyone starts hating them.
It’s almost unthinkable, why in the name
of Odin would normal people hate The Avengers?
I have a couple theories.
Let’s look at the plot.
We know it’s loosely inspired by the comic
Mighty Avengers, beginning after Civil War.
Ultron, who already existed via Hank Pym,
co-opts one of Tony Stark’s Iron Man suits.
And for a little while, it seems like Iron
Man is the villain.
Albeit a fake Iron Man.
But normal people don’t know that.
So you can see why people might start hating
on the Avengers.
The movie is a little different.
Because Ultron doesn’t exist yet, as far
as we know.
He has to have an origin story.
In the comics, Hank Pym creates him.
In the movies, because we won’t see that
character until three months after Avengers
2, they changed the origin.
Now Ultron is loosely based on a Military
version of JARVIS, that just spins out of
control.
Captain America The Winter Soldier kind of
sets the stage for how all this is possible.
How the military could come into possession
of something so dangerous as a rogue AI.
But because it’s essentially Stark Tech,
the Avengers get blamed.
By the public that is.
And you get your ‘evil Avengers’.
But there’s so much other stuff that has
to happen in this movie to resolve the Ultron
situation and set things up for Phase 3 and
the Infinity Gems.
What has to happen in order for people to
believe in the Avengers again?
You have to kill one of them, you have to
kill one of the bright shining stars of the
Avengers.
Captain America.
Crazy, I know.
But it’s been done before, for different
reasons.
Remember Captain America died at the conclusion
of Civil War, before being resurrected later.
So even if Joss Whedon kills him, he’ll
be back.
Remember, there’s no such thing as permanent
death in comic books and comic book movies.
Why do I think it’s going to be Captain
America?
Mostly because in a recent interview, Chris
Evans said he thinks he’ll be done with
the character by 2017.
Which is just enough time to squeeze out a
third Captain America film.
And there have been rumors that the Winter
Soldier might potentially replace him.
Which happened after he was killed in the
comics during Civil War.
If you’re not familiar, I’m talking about
the character of The Winter Soldier taking
up the costume and shield of Captain America,
not Sebastian Stan.
The alternate theory is that it’s Hawkeye
who will be killed, Coulson style, to bring
everyone together.
Meaning Captain America’s death could just
be postponed till the third film.
Either way, the Avengers will be very unpopular
until something catalyzes public opinion post-Ultron.
And Chris Evans’ status as Captain America
was just upgraded to ‘might be gone soon’.
If you consider 2017 to be soon.
In my opinion major roster changes in characters
and actors in general isn’t going to happen
until Avengers 3, maybe even phase 4.
Even the most expensive person, Robert Downey
Jr, has a contract that extends through Avengers
3.
Which is scheduled for 2019 right now.
So now it’s your turn to let me know, do
you think everyone is going to blame Tony
Stark and the Avengers for the creation of
Ultron and all the destruction he causes?
And what is going to happen to fix that?
I think it has to be a dead Avenger.
Who it is, is still up for debate.
So Captain America is out next week.
I’ll post a review of that Thursday night,
not this thursday, next week.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
I’ll probably do my next Marvel Movie video
on my top picks for new Avengers.
Right now click here to learn more about Avengers
2 and click here for my top picks for Captain
America 3.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!